Hello 我是小专临
请给你们看一下我六年前的皮膚状态
盲孔粗大 脸上各种小颗里小颗
打摸起来很蓝 少
但你们看一下我现在的素严
非常的心理光滑
而且脸上经常是那种自带水光感的
我发现油豆皮想要皮膚快速变好减静
就是用算
这个是我的亲身经历
但我发现现在居然还有很多的油皮减肥都不敢用算
所以今天我就手把手的分享
怎么用算你们直接召发我这套流程
皮膚也可以越来越好
豆豆皮口粉丝黑头都会减少
很多而且不容易翻车
第一个如果是新手小白的话
你洗完脸之后
记得把脸上的这个水分都参干
那是老手的话
就在用算之前能先有一个噴霧打底
可以促进酸的滩头
现在就可以上脸了
我用的是这个我很喜欢的
薄的打扫
酸洞磨
我大概能一般会几两个手指节这样
就把它图在额头
踢匙
还有下巴
练架
所以叫安城的地方
咱们可以后途一些
这个酸它这个是超好用
它里面是用的沙洋酸
还有超分子的缓剩几书
一边做清几书
通一边做修户
就很适合新手入门
就是如果是第一次用的话
可能会感觉有点自刺的
但是没关系
已经是正常的
过个几分钟
这种感觉就没有了
我现在是除了家庭白
修之外
我日常也是很喜欢用的
我感觉它就是让我的毛泡变得很通差
豆豆出有都减少了
平时皮膚就是那种
十路路的水光机的养腹
接着这三部用的腹腻
做一个冰风
这也不很关键
有的姐妹一用酸就会
特别养特别刺了
你冰肤的话可以很拉成肚减少
次次的感觉会双缓很多
新手服务的五分钟
就可以去洗掉了
那老手的话可以腹十到十五分钟
刚刚把脸洗干净了
现在我来分享几个
这和酸后用的
恢复搭配
都是我亲自下来效果很好的
让我们再来把酸的作用拉大鞋
首先是这个三期精华
大家去美容愿用酸吃后
他们都会给你
再用一个修护精华
这一部对于刚刚用酸的小白蓝
说是非常重要的
它里面是不加香精
防护记得容易治理的东西
成分也比较精减
主大成分是三期总造干
它可以快速的酸华修护
把脸上的红火给压下去
而且它还复配了
长面酸和百分之一的超分子
是要酸
让皮膚围持在一个若酸性的状态
这样各有利于皮膚修护
同时还能減少皮膚
受刺激而产生期的色产的问题
我一般会用它塗了两层
就感觉皮膚外面加了一层精中这样
让我偷偏安心
很适合有命机或者是动玩项目
想要快速修护的姐妹
想要百白的姐妹
可以在用完酸之后加一个温和不刺激的白白精华
因为用完酸之后皮膚通道已经打开了
它能促进白白精华的新手
出来的效果会更好
全相皮的姐妹还可以更来搭配
就是用完了酸动模之后
再来一个一层精华
这一套就是那么幅的效果很绝
可以帮我们心理皮膚黑老一机说猫口
最后呢
会再来一个修护的面双精协
工程调用酸材不会容易翻成
好了
人经济的用酸分享就到这里了
因为没有发现
真现在皮膚感觉就很有光滋了
游皮游其实游豆皮的姐妹
你们一定要把酸用起来
坚持的正确用酸皮膚真的会越来越吸你越来越好